So with all the rising costs of meat,
I decided that we're gonna raise our own meat birds this year.
Although we have raised chickens for years,
this is the first time we've been raising chickens just to eat them,
which is a weird process, because normally I'm so upset when they die
because they're my little egg layers.
But this time, they're specifically purchased to raise,
so it's the same. They arrived,
they were just these cute little fluff balls,
but they grew really fast.
I did get some egg layers at the same time,
and you can see the rapid growth compared to the egg layers.
These birds are designed specifically to grow meat.
These are Freedom rangers.
They do grow slower than the Cornish cross.
They grow really, really fast.
These are like a medium speed,
I would say. They have less disease,
and they grow at a nice pace,
but they still grow really fast.
Butcher day couldn't come soon enough.
They. They were eating everything within sight.
Our chickens don't normally eat that much.
They have a little bit of grain left over from the cow,
and they eat all the bugs on pasture.
But with these chickens, they were eating every bug inside,
and there was no food left.
So they were eating a lot of grain,
and they were putting a lot of pressure on the other chickens
that we already have. Also the poop.
They. We have 17 acres,
but they love To hang out by the house.
So they were pooping on a lot of stuff,
so it was definitely time.
We could have butchered A few weeks before this,
so we just didn't have the time to do it.
We end up purchasing this plucker,
because I'm probably gonna do this again in the future,
but I won't buy as many birds,
because this was a lot of birds disorder.
We still have half of them out there on the pasture,
and we don't have the freezer space.
I'm gonna get a new freezer.
It was a great learning experience for the kids,
and I would definitely recommend to try this out for yourselves.